5 cubed is 125, that's because five
cubed equals five times five times five.
Two to the fifth is 32,
two to the fifth is two
times two times two times two times two.
One to the seventh is one,
that's because one times one is one.
No matter how many times we multiply
one by itself, it still equals one.
Four to the fourth is 256,
that's because four to
the fourth is four times
four times four times four.
These are easier to do
with a calculator but
here are some tricks to
do them by hand too.
You can pair things together,
so two times two is four and
then four times four is 16.
And then I have one two left over, so
four times four times two is
16 times two which is 32.
Same thing with five,
five times five is 25 and
then we multiply it by five,
25 times five equals 125.
[BLANK_AUDIO]